Amerika Amerika is a younger country are
you still at all optimistic Hillary I am
fundamentally optimistic I mean there's
all these little indicators of people
trying to turn the clock back and push
back the progress that David was
referencing so that does worry me but I
think when it's all hopefully worked out
here and there people will say wait a
minute you know there's things we need
to be smarter about do better about but
let's not turn the clock back for heaven
sakes and it's interesting in the book
there's a American sports with an
American soccer star Abby Wambach and
she's extraordinary she scored more
goals and than any man or woman ever
ever when she came to the end of her
career she did this final kind of
endorsement advertising campaign and the
tagline was forget me why did that
appeal to you Hillary well what she was
saying as she retired was you know I
want to make way for new people you know
forget me forget my accomplishments
let's clear the decks let's encourage
more young people not only to play
football but run for office be a great
chef be a writer be whatever and I loved
that because in our house we had a
saying about you know how important it
was also to be second you know somebody
could be the first to something but that
didn't mean that you would stop pursuing
your own dreams you could be the second
the third the hundredth you would be
doing what you were meant to do and I
think Abby's you know really
inspirational speech that she gave a few
years ago mostly aimed at young women
was you've got to go out and do what
you're afraid to do you've got to take
the risks to be who you know deep in
your heart you should be and I'm gonna
get off the stage because I want another
great footballer up here I want somebody
else who is you know gonna beat my
records and I love that because that is
what we should be doing to tell the next
generation and where are you are you
saying forget me is that your mantra now
not yet
[Applause]
because the rumor mill is flying you
could step back into the ring yeah I
hear that
I especially have been deluged and you
know the last few weeks with thinking
about doing that but right now I'm not
at all you know planning that I'd have
to make up my mind really quickly
because it's moving very fast but I do
want to continue to influence the debate
you know I'm not I'm not leaving you
know the political arena completely I'm
working really hard to you know make it
clear that we have to hold our current
leadership accountable so I'm on Twitter
I'm not as I think clever as Chelsea is
it you know dealing with a lot of the
undercurrents of Twitter but I'm out
there all the time sort of pointing out
some of the foolishness and craziness
that we are currently experiencing so
you know I'm not going anywhere I just
don't know what role I will be actually
in but I'm looking at Chelsea and I'm
thinking this is your mom and you're
hearing she's not ruling out the idea of
running again does your blood run cold
your mother goes through that again I
mean she is first and foremost my mom do
you think sometimes people forget I mean
as proud as I am of everything that
she's done she's first before was my mom
and I guess maybe now my kids
grandmother yeah and so of course I feel
like protective of her but I know that
you know she'll continue to not only
influence the debate but help push the
debate forward however she does that I'm
in her corner Graham like whatever she
decides to do but that's for her to
decide well whatever you decide to do
come on I see you again
[Applause]
[Music]
you